alright guys we are taking the peanuts
cracking them open and getting the seeds
ready we're gonna be planting some
peanuts this year hi foresters this is
where we're going to put the peanuts and
I'm just I put some compost down a
little bit more topsoil just trying to
amend the soil a little bit it's some
really good rich stuff anyways but so
we're going to do is I'm just mixing it
all in and loosening up the soil because
peanuts need loose soil and we're going
to plant these things about a foot and a
half apart so I'm gonna go ahead and
finish mixing this up and we'll get back
to you with the planting
- maybe the eggplant we had in there
could be that big gigantic thing
[Music]
all right here's the nuts we had to take
them out of the shell you just show them
you got to use raw peanuts these are
from Burpee so these are seed peanuts
you can get just you can go out and buy
the green peanuts but we're so we're
going to plant these about a foot and a
half apart 18 inches or 16 inches oh
that would be 18 inches about 18 inches
apart that but some of these might be a
little close but they'll be all right
and about a foot and about I'm gonna
drop two in
[Music]
you
we have leftovers we have to make us
another little patch somewhere all right
we can keep I can put them in a little
ziplock bag all right all right now what
do you do now we cover them up just
loosely yeah you know what we can just
keep a hold of these extras in case a
squirrel sniff these out yeah because we
got to worry about swirls or oil to be
loose wherever I put my hands I need
that yeah
that's gonna be so cool if we can grow
our own peanuts alright now we just got
to clean up huh
[Music]